[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
therapy that's good i guess i don't know
therapy is good
i'm def you like it
it helps
you stick with it
i should
i like her tone she's like clearly it
has not made a dent so
are you picking up on some problems
no are you in it sorry if someone was
telling me i can't talk to you oh no
it's all right
i think i got i got final say up here i
think
what
oh
yeah well you know what were you saying
i i think you were telling me to stick
in therapies what happened
well are you in therapy
you really want to go you got some big
balls
not being in therapy and being like you
really got to stay with therapy
you can't afford it yeah that's a
problem i'm doing pretty well
and also not well
strange combo
it's weird to brag how well are you
doing i got that [ __ ] therapy money
dude
yeah i'm [ __ ] rolling in it
i go four times a month
america's a bad place
we're the best but we're also isn't that
weird
they'll be like man i just i gotta get
to a place you used to be like you're a
homeowner now you're like i just need to
see a clinical psychiatrist
today's monday august 22nd and samurail
has a new special coming out on netflix
on september 1st right now he has his
interview with david letterman on
netflix and then he has two youtube
specials so this will be his first
special on netflix and it's very
exciting he announced on instagram today
it's gonna be called same time tomorrow
and it comes out in a week and a half
welcome back to the joke world comedy
update every single monday bringing you
the comedy news that you need to know
whether it be new specials comedians
going on each other's podcasts anything
happening with your favorite comics your
favorite shows all in one place so
please consider subscribing to the
channel right now following us on
spotify and downloading this to support
the show
sam has two specials available right now
on youtube the one on comedy central's
channel called i got this that is 10
million views from about two years ago
and then he released one during covid on
his own channel that has about two
million views called up on the roof
comedy clubs are closed but i still want
to do stand-up i think we just got to
get people's roofs
get a mic an amp that's all we need
camera crew you
dom a few other people we shoot it
we cut it up that's a special
good
even with the success of these youtube
specials 10 million views and 2 million
views he has not had one on netflix yet
so this will be his first one on netflix
and it's interesting because tim dillon
was just doing some podcast rounds
promoting his new netflix special that
came out last week and he said that
netflix gave him no notes on the special
whatsoever he said whatever he wanted it
was a very tim dillon-esque dark humor
special and i'd expect that samurails
would be the same way no notes it seems
like these youtube specials are starting
to make the streaming services wake up a
little bit and realize these comedians
can do this on their own so they better
stop trying to critique their art change
the jokes i saw porno once the guy uh
he's sleeping and he gets uh he gets
wakened up by by a [ __ ]
it's the worst way to wake up
why
no it's fantastic
i don't know you i don't know your
sarcasm
he's like that's horrible my wife i
don't i don't know tonight yet
sounds threatening
not yet you don't know me
you will someday
i have high hopes for this special when
it comes out in a week and a half i will
definitely be watching on the post
announcing it on instagram he got some
comments from the comic world krista
stefano weighing in saying yes tom
segura calling him the best joke writer
today so that's high praise from some
other great comedians i'm definitely
gonna be watching on netflix september
1st your mom's house live number eight
came out last wednesday and it was as
advertised i would say i bought the 10
version i didn't do the 50 version with
the josh potter pre-show and and the
merch that you got but the 10 version
was awesome they shot a few sketches
beforehand that had very high quality
production tim dillon was great talking
about his special and reacting to the
heavy segments and the heavy segments
were
so disgusting
i personally drew the line when they
showed the video of a guy putting a
leech into his dick hole
um
up to that point it was a great two
hours very very funny and i think it's
still available today for sale so if you
want to check it out i would definitely
recommend it tim dillon was hilarious on
it uh just
beware of the heavy segment for real
it's no joke
it's disgusting tim dillon had a netflix
special come out last week called a true
hero and like we talked about before in
this episode tim dillon mentioned that
netflix gave him no notes on any of his
jokes let everything stay in which is
great because we all know the story of
andrew schultz and him buying his own
special back from a streamer after
selling it and then wanting to change
some jokes so it's good to see netflix
taking the side of comedians in this
case and it seems like that'll be what
happens moving forward thank you
everybody for watching the special and
your
kind words trended on netflix for uh
about a week maybe still trending don't
know one of the top
search things on that platform we really
appreciate that as well as you know tom
segura and joe rogan having me on to
uh
hang out promote that with them had fun
discussions with
both of those gentlemen and christina p
we did a crazy live stream at your mom's
house and then we did joe
the next day while we were down in texas
and now we are back
um
here in los angeles and um
uh really excited a lot of people really
uh
feedback is very positive so we're happy
about that and
you know it's uh you know it's good to
to have it out there and done and then
you know we are moving on we also made a
video collecting the fans reactions to
tim dillon special you can link it up
here if you want to know what the comedy
community thought of the new special the
guest list from last week your mom's
house had on johnny pemberton two bears
one cave was burton whitney so good luck
with that one tiger belly was chad and
jt go deep the joe rogan experience had
a great week last week they had on tim
dillon louis c.k and joe list ancient
cultures were obsessed with
constellations and we don't give a [ __ ]
about them first they built [ __ ] like
that together yes yeah and also built
things that mimicked the constellations
like the mayans and the egyptians this
the way they formulated their structures
it all like aligned with certain
constellations and it was very important
to them well think about back when
people were before there was like
skyscrapers airplanes that you couldn't
go up you could only go like six feet
high right right and you could maybe
build something that was like i don't
know threes like a a castle yeah that's
kind of high but those pyramids and
i know i sound like an idiot and
something you guys [ __ ] dropped acid
while i was watching oj
i just got wacky in here that was hills
there's mountains right whiskey ginger
was annie letterman kill tony tonight
was jeff ross the roast master and
flagrant was true jordy what's the
origin of your back and forth with
andrew tate this is a guy who missed a
few hugs of his mother i mean there's
videos of him slapping women around
online i couldn't give a [ __ ] about
audrey would you box him yeah he come up
to me in my face i would absolutely
punch him in the face but am i gonna
make effort to go running every morning
no i don't care
i've got a business to run i'm not gonna
take time out to worry about andrew i'm
not like him i'm not daddy's little rich
boy i gotta
get him oh did he come for money oh he
come from money yeah i'm not just
talking about the human trafficking
money that you start either i'm talking
about you'll still keep them going for
another fourth and years
you guys are gonna be best friends like
two years yeah i'll be making money off
of his dumps as well so andrew you're
fighting floyd mayweather then i'm
joking i'm joking
battle of the rapist him and floyd that
would make for a good one
to be fair specials from last week you
had tim dillon on netflix mike cannon on
youtube released a crowd work special
and then a few months ago jim brewer's
new special called somebody had to say
it and sam morrell announcing his
special coming out on september 1st
thank you for watching this episode of
the joke world comedy update every
monday bring you the comedy news please
remember to subscribe follow us on
instagram to support the channel
download this on spotify thank you guys
so much for watching and we'll see you
again next monday
[Music]
you